you
Mass Effect Andromeda there are so many
things to wish for from Mass Effect
things that we had before and things
that we haven't I think for me one of
the biggest things would be to see
Bioware really expand that world I don't
know that it needs to be open world but
I'd like a whole lot more space to
explore instead of being funneled down
medium to large-sized map mass effect is
all about discovery and so what I wanted
Mass Effect Andromeda is the ability to
go out and explore big open worlds I
want the ability to go out like some of
the Mass Effect 1 levels and just roam
around a planet finding what's their
combat areas that are much larger a
greater emphasis on the exploration in
general I don't know that it means to
take the dragon age inquisition route
but I do really want to see more space
to cover in general and maybe that means
vehicles I want to take a Mako and just
go driving that's what I want to do in
Mass Effect Andromeda I really want it
to be bigger in that way I want it to be
I want there to be more things to
explore and discover and if they can
pull that off that would make Mass
Effect Andromeda something really
special in my opinion I'd really love
you know the freedom to not only be on
the ground and drive around on the
ground but also the freedom to be in the
air give me something to do in space
that isn't just picking a place and
going to it and scanning a planet or
something you know give me control full
control of my ship and let's find out
what I
in in a new mass effect i think i'd like
to just get rid of the whole saving the
universe for trying to find the
MacGuffin kind of thing that's happened
in that was I guess the main plot in
Mass Effect one too but certainly ended
up being the main focus of three in the
end and so getting rid of that and
focusing more I'm sort of interesting
like smaller tales that exist in that
universe something that they're very
good at is making relationships and
teaching you to really value them and
navigating them and sort of figuring out
who you like and I don't know I'm just
talking about everything they're doing
because I'm thinking about it what's
really going on in my head isn't
thinking about those tastefully done sex
scenes with Shepherd and liara and the
sighing and the music and the flights
and whatever I am hoping that Mass
Effect Andromeda keeps that and keeps
their relationship system and keeps that
like really tantalizing sexy sex stuff
they were technically superior in lots
of ways but graphically they were always
pretty fantastic and I think if I drama
is going to come out up to these
consoles been out for so long then it
kind of needs to be one of those games
that really like pushes the envelope
that way one of the biggest things that
I want to see in Mass Effect Andromeda
is just the continuation of co-op that
we had in Mass Effect 3 so they didn't
have co-op in the actual campaign but
they had this fantastic competitive
co-op mode where you have like Batarian
bounty hunters you had Krogan warlord
you inspectors you know you had sorry
you had all the races and everything
they really need to let players not be
commander shepard to let them be all of
these other creatures in the Mass Effect
universe that's fantastic so you know if
there was ever game that asks for co-op
be taken from that competitive
multiplayer into the single-player
exploration I think it's got to be Mass
Effect Andromeda
the